illusion projection involves depicting a  detailed image from outside oneself  which is perceptible in the external  world whereas duplication casting  entails recreating an exact facsimile of  one's own body in its present  circumstance which acts as a true  holographic mirror of its molecular  structure  but  you already knew that  [Music]  [Applause]  really gonna make me do it do what  you know that nothing will stop me  as it returns to my hand not even your  face you go quite mad you you'll be  executed for this i'll see you on the  other side brother  all right i  yield no  [Music]  are you ever not going to fall for that  [Music]  patrice  it's been a long time  you're as beautiful as that  patrice never said a thing that nice in  30 years  [Music]  being told you one thing and  learning it's all a fiction  [Music]  i mean you didn't think i'd really come  and see you did this place is disgusting  [Music]  not bad  [Music]  you